i'm a filmmaker writer film professor
and founder of kinovat.com an online
digital film studio
i'm here to talk about the future of
storytelling my name is asmara
i love my name as a child because it was
listed in the thick dictionary we had
it was there because it is a city and
happened to be in bold at the top as a
search heading
that made me feel important there's a
story about my name that comes from
tigrinya
it means mara which means
the four are united the story goes that
the male leaders of the four villages
were fighting
the women came together and calmed
tensions by creating the capital city of
asmara
they united the four i am named after
that city which lies high in the
mountains of east africa
i'll share with you my thoughts about
storytelling first about storytellers
then about technology and finally the
media industry
my thoughts about the future
paradoxically are grounded in the past
and the natural world
there are four directions on the compass
and four elements in nature
earth symbolizes stability water our
subconscious air the mind and fire
action and change
a hopi prophecy symbolized by this
medicine wheel says that
long ago the great spirit gathered the
peoples of this earth together and said
i'm going to send you to four directions
and change you to four colors
i'll give you special teachings to the
red people i give guardianship over the
earth
to the black people over water to the
yellow people
guardianship over air and the white
people guardianship over fire
when you come back together you will
share these so that you can live and
have peace on earth and a great
civilization will come about
if you do not share not only will human
beings have a hard time but almost the
earth itself
will die the animated series avatar
depicts a version of this tale a world
that is out of balance with the fire
nation having too much power
so my first point about the future of
storytelling
is that it has to be inclusive not as a
favor
or out of pity to anyone left out but as
an urgent necessity
to create a comprehensive global
knowledge system
for example i'm in california right now
and concerned i might miss this talk
because my power could be cut off to
avoid another massive fire
years ago settlers in this area banned
native american tribes from performing
controlled burns which cleaned forests
thus preventing large-scale wildfires
this practice took thousands of years to
develop it is part of our overlooked
knowledge system and we need it now
next i would like to speak with you
about technology which some fear is
burning out of control and
nature of storytelling the term ludite
refers to someone who opposes
technological advancements the word
comes from a band of english workers who
destroyed machinery especially textile
mills
because they feared the machines would
take their jobs now we know that
technology usually creates new jobs just
different kinds of them
today we feel robots taking over and
humans becoming surplus we are anxious
that social media is a nexus of
misinformation
and distortion bringing the downfall of
not only democracy but even human
decency in the film the red desert
directed by antonioni the main character
anxiously wanders around barren
landscapes haunted by the loud sound of
machinery painted in audacious colors
film critics said it showed the problems
of industry but antonioni said
you don't quite understand the problem
is not the machines the problem is the
humans who have not yet adapted
we can't solve global problems with
national structures and we need
technology to unite the global community
we don't need to fear an upgrade of tech
as much as we need
to upgrade ourselves we must evolve
spiritually emotionally and
psychologically to make use of new and
emerging technological tools to better
ourselves and society and to share our
local stories internationally
as for the industry the business of
storytelling particularly finance is
changing through blockchain technology
film productions have followed the same
globalization path of other industries
going abroad for tax incentives
so that where the story takes place has
little or no relation to where it is
filmed or whose story it is
this has to change we need local hubs of
storytelling
we need to develop global financial
structures that create equitable pay for
everyone in the
industry we need to respect the story
itself the author
and the people who live these stories to
tell stories with integrity empathy and
compassion to think that well maybe the
indians aren't the bad guys fighting to
protect the land for themselves
maybe they are fighting to protect it
for everybody including you so to
summarize the future of storytelling is
inclusive
it is high-tech it is empathetic it
operates on a higher spiritual
psychological
and emotional plane than where we are
now it is time to unite the four
directions the four corners and the four
peoples of the earth
the four are united asmara
i recently learned that asmara also
means love in malay from sanskrit
so let's unite the four and let's do it
with love thank you
thank you asmara and one of the things i
like about your talk
is that it is a talk about storytelling
and packed as an example of how to do an
amazing story so what how did you select
your opening gambit that pulls us all in
uh
with my name or you mean the hopi
prophecy
uh your name i guess it just came
intuitively actually and
i've been fascinated by that hopi story
and i actually never
realized this link that the four are
united is also the hopi story and that
it happened in eritrea which is where my
father was born
so that was a new discovery for me that
inspired me to share